we're here to discuss these developments
and more is kevin torelli
chief washington correspondent for
bloomberg television and anchor of the
program
sound on bloomberg radio kevin welcome
thank you for having me for the first
time in more than a decade democrats
control the house and the senate as well
as the white house and even so president
biden is
reaching across that aisle to pass his
1.9
trillion dollar covid relief package
will there be any republican support for
a bill with that many
zeros incredibly unlikely yesterday i
spoke with a senior source
to a republican senator who essentially
said if democrats go the route of a
process that they've set up for next
week known as budget reconciliation
then ultimately virtually no republicans
will get on board with 1.9
trillion dollars worth of economic
stimulus now when i talk to democrats
and when i talk to sources connected to
the white house
they say that this is still going to
likely be on
path for passage sometime between now
and
march but what essentially has become a
political poison pill for republicans
are increasing the amount of checks to a
fourteen hundred dollar checks that
could go out
uh progressives in the house and the
senate say that's not enough money they
wanna see it
uh upwards of two thousand dollars
people like congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
but also raising the minimum wage to
fifteen dollars an hour republicans say
right now small businesses small
restaurants
wouldn't be able to afford that they
simply say
this is too much money uh that that
quite frankly america just cannot afford
at this current time
if republicans are in agreement over
this right now there still seems to be
divide
in the party we talk about it being the
party of trump whether it still is where
do the republicans stand right now
well we have seen the in the past week
all of this political tension amongst
republicans really
bubble over especially as it relates to
the third highest ranking
house member liz cheney in which she had
voted for impeachment
against now former president donald
trump we've seen republicans still
aligned with president trump
come out forcefully and criticize her
for that vote but again when i talked to
republicans this week
what they essentially said to me was
look
75 million americans voted for president
trump for re-election
but they didn't necessarily vote for the
insurrection that occurred at the
capitol
and as a result of that there is this
open discussion that is happening about
the best path forward
for the republican party for leadership
for a new generation of republicans
in terms of the direction that the party
should take at the start of the
2022 election cycle and you saw
uh minority leader kevin mccarthy
meeting with president trump
just within the last couple of days and
trying to figure out
again that direction for the party
that's the long-term future kevin but
but very quickly what's what's the
short-term strategy the republican
leadership strategy
for that impeachment trial what are you
hearing from mitch mcconnell's folks
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
jeff is is trying to figure out uh the
timetable there's some politics behind
the scene that suggests that he might
feel that a longer term trial would be
uh in the benefit for republicans but
likely what i heard from the source
yesterday was a march timetable for that
trial
okay kevin thank you very much thank you